and out of control Wildfire scorches
Spain's northern coast the rough terrain
high winds and low humidity are
hampering firefighters battling the
flames
Spain's Wildfire season started early
this year in the Eastern Valencia region
more than 4 000 hectares of forest were
destroyed last week and 1500 people were
forced to abandon their homes they've
only just been allowed to return
it's a feeling of joy for all of us
coming back home is fundamentally a very
important thing we love the community we
belong to the community so you can
imagine how relieved I feel
the un's environment agency says climate
change will spark a 30 increase in
severe wildfires by the middle of the
century in Spain they're already dealing
with the Fallout the country's Wildfire
season now runs from Spring to Autumn
not just during the summer and Spain's
meteorological agency says temperatures
in March have been up to 14 degrees
higher than normal it's a new reality
people are struggling to adjust to
foreign
authorities have brought us a bottle of
water because they have told us that we
cannot drink from the Taps all the food
in my freezer is defrosted it's bad
everything is ruined
with warmer weather forecast in the
weeks to come scenes like this are
likely to play out again for many more
months Victoria gate and B Al Jazeera